Hi, I’m Carrie Anne, and welcome to CrashCourse
Computer Science!
As we talked about last episode, your computer
is connected to a large, distributed network,
called The Internet.
I know this because you’re watching a youtube
video, which is being streamed over that very
internet.
It’s arranged as an ever-enlarging web of
interconnected devices.
For your computer to get this video, the first
connection is to your local area network,
or LAN, which might be every device in your
house that’s connected to your wifi router.
This then connects to a Wide Area Network,
or WAN, which is likely to be a router run
by your Internet Service Provider, or ISP
– companies like Comcast, AT&T or Verizon.
At first, this will be a regional router,
like one for your neighborhood, and then that
router connects to an even bigger WAN, maybe
one for your whole city or town.
There might be a couple more hops, but ultimately
you’ll connect to the backbone of the internet
made up of gigantic routers with super high-bandwidth
connections running between them.
To request this video file from youtube, a
packet had to work its way up to the backbone,
travel along that for a bit, and then work
its way back down to a youtube server that
had the file.
That might be four hops up, two hops across
the backbone, and four hops down, for a total
of ten hops.
If you’re running Windows, MacOS or Linux,
you can see the route data takes to different
places on the internet by using the traceroute
program on your computer.
Instructions in the Doobly Doo.
For us here at the Chad & Stacey Emigholz
Studio in Indianapolis, the route to the DFTBA
server in California goes through 11 stops.
We start at 192.168.0.1 -- thats the IP address
for my computer on our LAN.
Then there’s the wifi router here at the
studio, then a series of regional routers,
then we get onto the backbone, and then we
start working back down to the computer hosting
“DFTBA dot com”, which has the IP address
104.24.109.186.
But how does a packet actually get there?
What happens if a packet gets lost along the
way?
If I type “DFTBA dot com” into my web
browser, how does it know the server’s address?
Those are our topics for today!
INTRO
As we discussed last episode, the internet
is a huge distributed network that sends data
around as little packets.
If your data is big enough, like an email
attachment, it might get broken up into many
packets.
For example, this video stream is arriving
to your computer right now as a series of
packets, and not one gigantic file.
Internet packets have to conform to a standard
called the Internet Protocol, or IP.
It’s a lot like sending physical mail through
the postal system – every letter needs a
unique and legible address written on it,
and there are limits to the size and weight
of packages.
Violate this, and your letter won’t get
through.
IP packets are very similar.
However, IP is a very low level protocol – there
isn’t much more than a destination address
in a packet’s header, which is the metadata
that’s stored in front of the data payload.
This means that a packet can show up at a
computer, but the computer may not know which
application to give the data to; Skype or
Call of Duty.
For this reason, more advanced protocols were
developed that sit on top of IP.
One of the simplest and most common is the
User Datagram Protocol, or UDP.
UDP has its own header, which sits inside
the data payload.
Inside of the UDP header is some useful, extra
information.
One of them is a port number.
Every program wanting to access the internet
will ask its host computer’s Operating System
to be given a unique port.
Like Skype might ask for port number 3478.
When a packet arrives to the computer, the
Operating System will look inside the UDP
header and read the port number.
Then, if it sees, for example, 3478, it will
give the packet to Skype.
So to review, IP gets the packet to the right
computer, but UDP gets the packet to the right
program running on that computer.
UDP headers also include something called
a checksum, which allows the data to be verified
for correctness.
As the name suggests, it does this by checking
the sum of the data.
Here’s a simplified version of how this
works.
Lets imagine the raw data in our UDP packet
is 89 111 33 32 58 and 41.
Before the packet is sent, the transmitting
computer calculates the checksum by adding
all the data together: 89 plus 111 plus 33
and so on.
In our example, this adds up to a checksum
of 364.
In UDP, the checksum value is stored in 16
bits.
If the sum exceeds the maximum possible value,
the upper-most bits overflow, and only the
lower bits are used.
Now, when the receiving computer gets this
packet, it repeats the process, adding up
all the data.
89 plus 111 plus 33 and so on.
If that sum is the same as the checksum sent
in the header, all is well.
But, if the numbers don’t match, you know
that the data got corrupted at some point
in transit, maybe because of a power fluctuation
or faulty cable.
Unfortunately, UDP doesn’t offer any mechanisms
to fix the data, or request a new copy – receiving
programs are alerted to the corruption, but
typically just discard the packet.
Also, UDP provides no mechanisms to know if
packets are getting through – a sending
computer shoots the UDP packet off, but has
no confirmation it ever gets to its destination
successfully.
Both of these properties sound pretty catastrophic,
but some applications are ok with this, because
UDP is also really simple and fast.
Skype, for example, which uses UDP for video
chat, can handle corrupt or missing packets.
That’s why sometimes if you’re on a bad
internet connection,
Skype gets all glitchy – only some of the
UDP packets are making it to your computer.
Skype does the best it can with the data it
does receive correctly.
But this approach doesn’t work for many
other types of data transmission.
Like, it doesn’t really work if you send
an email, and it shows up with the middle
missing.
The whole message really needs to get there
correctly!
When it “absolutely, positively needs to
get there”, programs use the Transmission
Control Protocol, or TCP, which like UDP,
rides inside the data payload of IP packets.
For this reason, people refer to this combination
of protocols as TCP/IP.
Like UDP, the TCP header contains a destination
port and checksum.
But, it also contains fancier features, and
we’ll focus on the key ones.
First off, TCP packets are given sequential
numbers.
So packet 15 is followed by packet 16, which
is followed by 17, and so on... for potentially
millions of packets sent during that session.
These sequence numbers allow a receiving computer
to put the packets into the correct order,
even if they arrive at different times across
the network.
So if an email comes in all scrambled, the
TCP implementation in your computer’s operating
system will piece it all together correctly.
Second, TCP requires that once a computer
has correctly received a packet – and the
data passes the checksum – that it send
back an acknowledgement, or “ACK” as the
cool kids say, to the sending computer.
Knowing the packet made it successfully, the
sender can now transmit the next packet.
But this time, let’s say, it waits, and
doesn’t get an acknowledgement packet back.
Something must be wrong If enough time elapses,
the sender will go ahead and just retransmit
the same packet.
It’s worth noting that the original packet
might have actually gotten there, but the
acknowledgment is just really delayed.
Or perhaps it was the acknowledgment that
was lost.
Either way, it doesn’t matter, because the
receiver has those sequence numbers, and if
a duplicate packet arrives, it can be discarded.
Also, TCP isn’t limited to a back and forth
conversation – it can send many packets,
and have many outstanding ACKs, which increases
bandwidth significantly, since you aren’t
wasting time waiting for acknowledgment packets
to return.
Interestingly, the success rate of ACKs, and
also the round trip time between sending and
acknowledging, can be used to infer network
congestion.
TCP uses this information to adjust how aggressively
it sends packets – a mechanism for congestion
control.
So, basically, TCP can handle out-of-order
packet delivery, dropped packets – including
retransmission – and even throttle its transmission
rate according to available bandwidth.
Pretty awesome!
You might wonder why anyone would use UDP
when TCP has all these nifty features.
The single biggest downside are all those
acknowledgment packets – it doubles the
number of messages on the network, and yet,
you're not transmitting any more data.
That overhead, including associated delays,
is sometimes not worth the improved robustness,
especially for time-critical applications,
like Multiplayer First Person Shooters.
And if it’s you getting lag-fragged you’ll
definitely agree!
When your computer wants to make a connection
to a website, you need two things - an IP
address and a port.
Like port 80, at 172.217.7.238.
This example is the IP address and port for
the Google web server.
In fact, you can enter this into your browser’s
address bar, like so, and you’ll end up
on the google homepage.
This gets you to the right destination, but
remembering that long string of digits would
be really annoying.
It’s much easier to remember: google.com.
So the internet has a special service that
maps these domain names to addresses.
It’s like the phone book for the internet.
And it’s called the Domain Name System,
or DNS for short.
You can probably guess how it works.
When you type something like “youtube.com”
into your web browser, it goes and asks a
DNS server – usually one provided by your
ISP – to lookup the address.
DNS consults its huge registry, and replies
with the address... if one exists.
In fact, if you try mashing your keyboard,
adding “.com”, and then hit enter in your
browser, you’ll likely be presented with
an error that says DNS failed.
That’s because that site doesn’t exist,
so DNS couldn’t give your browser an address.
But, if DNS returns a valid address, which
it should for “youtube.com”, then your
browser shoots off a request over TCP for
the website’s data.
There’s over 300 million registered domain
names, so to make that DNS Lookup a little
more manageable, it’s not stored as one
gigantically long list, but rather in a tree
data structure.
What are called Top Level Domains, or TLDs,
are at the very top.
These are huge categories like .com and .gov.
Then, there are lower level domains that sit
below that, called second level domains; Examples
under .com include google.com and
dftba.com.
Then, there are even lower level domains,
called subdomains, like images.google.com,
store.dftba.com.
And this tree is absolutely HUGE!
Like I said, more than 300 million domain
names, and that's just second level domain
names, not all the sub domains.
For this reason, this data is distributed
across many DNS servers, which are authorities
for different parts of the tree.
Okay, I know you’ve been waiting for it...
We’ve reached a new level of abstraction!
Over the past two episodes, we’ve worked
up from electrical signals on wires, or radio
signals transmitted through the air in the
case of wireless networks.
This is called the Physical Layer.
MAC addresses, collision detection, exponential
backoff and similar low level protocols that
mediate access to the physical layer are part
of the Data Link Layer.
Above this is the Network Layer, which is
where all the switching and routing technologies
that we discussed operate.
And today, we mostly covered the Transport
layer, protocols like UDP and TCP, which are
responsible for point to point data transfer
between computers, and also things like error
detection and recovery when possible.
We’ve also grazed the Session Layer – where
protocols like TCP and UDP are used to open
a connection, pass information back and forth,
and then close the connection when finished
– what’s called a session.
This is exactly what happens when you, for
example, do a DNS Lookup, or request a webpage.
These are the bottom five layers of the Open
System Interconnection (OSI) model, a conceptual
framework for compartmentalizing all these
different network processes.
Each level has different things to worry about
and solve, and it would be impossible to build
one huge networking implementation.
As we’ve talked about all series, abstraction
allows computer scientists and engineers to
be improving all these different levels of
the stack simultaneously, without being overwhelmed
by the full complexity.
And amazingly, we’re not quite done yet…
The OSI model has two more layers, the Presentation
Layer and the Application Layer, which include
things like web browsers, Skype, HTML decoding,
streaming movies and more.
Which we’ll talk about next week.
See you then.